-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"Why I Got Fired" stories
from you guys.
This first one's from
@Mishel0107.
She says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Is that a vodka?
-This one's from @BarChefPro.
-BarChefPro?
This person would know
what's in a rum and coke.
-He says...
-Well...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Honesty --
Honesty's the best policy.
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Slurred ] How many drunk days
are we allowed?
-Yeah.
[ Slurred ] Well,
they didn't know how to make
the rum and coke.
-[ Laughs ] Had some rum.
-And Captain Morgan
beat the crap outta me.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Normally ] This one's from
@virgogirl93.
I wonder if she went to school
with my friend Mark Reeves.
[ Laughter ]
She says...
-I doubt it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
It is worth it to get an
autograph from Ryan Reynolds.
I love that dude.
This one's from @Hollyb32.
She says...
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ The future is here ♪♪
♪♪ The future is here ♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-Uh...
This one's from
@MargoBe08471590.
[ Laughter ]
It's so catchy.
Just rolls off the tongue.
-Rolls off the tongue.
-Very easy to remember.
She says...
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Give me the music ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-That was Zelma.
-It's getting. It's getting.
-It's getting.
-No. Would you like --
Was that a different song?
-"I've Got the Power."
-Oh.
-That's "I've Got the Power"
you're thinking of.
-♪♪ Everybody d-- ♪♪
How's it go?
-♪♪ Everybody dance now ♪♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ I've got the power ♪♪
-♪♪ He-e-e-e-ey ♪♪
♪♪ I've got the power ♪♪
-♪♪ It's getting, it's getting,
it's getting kinda hectic ♪♪
♪♪ It's getting, it's getting,
-Love.
-Getting kinda hectic?
But then if you're in Walmart,
you're like,
"Uh, can you, uh,
help me move this TV?"
-Yeah.
-"Because it's getting,
it's getting,
it's getting kinda heavy.
♪♪ It's getting, it's getting,
it's getting kinda heavy ♪♪
♪♪ Everybody dance now ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Which one?
-"Everybody dance now,"
and then she's like,
"Give me the music," right?
-Uh-huh.
-Then she's like...?
-[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪♪♪
-Right.
-Oh, yeah. That's good.
-♪♪ I'm lovin' it ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
That's a different song.
-No? Different one?
-This one's from @kidatheart216.
-Aww.
She says,
"I booked a hotel overseas
so my boss could attend
a conference.
It turned out it was a brothel."
-Oh.
Oy!
-Oopsie.
-Zoink!
-[ Chuckles ]
It's like,
"Someone got a raise. Hey."
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from patchworkgreg.
Ooh, that sounds scary.
-Ooh, that sounds spicy.
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why don't you just pick up...?
-Yeah, fake phone.
-You just pick the phone
and fake it.
He probably got charged for it.
-[ Laughs ]
-Minutes -- ah, whatever.
This one's from hweir222.
He says...
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
I'm going to CVS.
-[ Imitates machine whirring ]
This last one's from
@MeganMary19.
She says...
There you go. Those are your
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more of our
favorites, go to...